When I started learning how to code,
I use the concept of learning zones
to help me map out my new
journey as a new programmer.
I always reflected on
the skills I was learning and
tracked whether I was in my safe zone,
where concepts are familiar and
where we don't need to take any risks.
Stretch zone where we're
introduced to new concepts, and
we're making new discoveries.
Or STRAIN zone,
where learning becomes difficult and
is often blocked by
sense of frustration.
The border between the STRETCH and
the STRAIN zone is the point
of maximum learning.
Our goal is to keep you between your
STRETCH and your STRAIN zone, so
you are always learning.
Whenever you learn something new you
may feel like your learning zones
are fluctuating.
One moment you could be
in your safe zone and
the next minute you're
in your strain zone.
This should be totally expected.
Learning something new especially
programming can be a winding journey
with many highs and lows.
Let's read a little bit more
about your learning zones.